what are five steps to writing a bad
book
only talking about yourself without a a
purpose or a mission
of something that you want to have the
reader experience like
joy or a journey
or an emotional release i'm talking more
in memoir and self-help
um using
language like it and this
and maybe and perhaps in like kind of
vague terms
instead of rewriting the sentences every
sentence should be a thing of beauty
um it's a book take your time
to make every line matter don't just
think well
those sentences were good these can be
kind of a slough off
rewrite every make every sentence
beautiful
um don't
aim low don't decide i'm just going to
write an ebook
and give it away for free on your
website i don't think that's not really
a book
honor books they're boundable
they're thicker it's something you want
to hand to someone and be proud of not
some door stop or something i'm going to
use to balance
my computer um that's
for and
five would be write one draft and then
publish it
why would someone do that people do it
all the time they're like that was
brilliant nailed it in one shot
and they just discount the whole process
that
that was just the beginning you read it
you can tell
you can tell when someone's published a
fir you don't see that in profession
professional but you see that in
you know when i was in like networking
groups or like you know first started my
business
people would write books in 90 days or
whatever
and you're like i don't want to read it
please don't give me your book this is
what i what i'd be thinking
because it would just be fluffy
it would spin it where they were
it
to really dig in and write a memoir in a
short period of time
i don't think it's got enough heft it
hasn't been expanded enough
um maybe to write a book about dating
like 101 tips to date you might be able
to do that in a first draft
um or
10 tips to good sales calls you might be
able to do that in one draft
but i don't tend to work with those
books
when you read an author's work and
they write about themselves into
positive alight
how do you break that down because we've
all read books where oh yeah it was
written by this ceo
or this person and they're just telling
their grand vision
and it paints them as this saint whereas
when you read about
a third party writing about that same
individual
it's much juicier it's a full person
warts and all so how do you when you see
somebody's being too
pollyanna about themselves how do you
say
are we really getting honest here i
don't ever get that
i don't ever get that i think that
there's a lot of self-deprecation
in the clients that come to me i think
that they've been through
enough of the rough road that
self-deprecation is not
it's not so far from them and um
if anything we're trying to get them to
be more positive about themselves
and and see where their beautiful gifts
are and see how what they've written
about and what they've been through
inform so much about who they are
um i don't i can't think of one
experience where someone just wants to
write
about their positive experiences i mean
i have had those conversations where
people have called me and they're like
well i'm going to write a book about and
i and i feel like kind of a cynic going
but where's the darkness
right especially when they say well
there really isn't anything dark about
my story and i think
oh i don't know if that's possible
who wants to read it where did you live
[Laughter]
yeah would you say a lot of new writers
write books that are mediocre or have no
essence
no not at all i mean i think it's i
think
everybody's a new writer on any project
you start i'm a new writer
even though i've been writing since i
was 12 years old
um anytime you take on a new narrative
or a new group of characters or maybe a
new style
of writing or you're going into new
territory you're new you know you might
have more of a bag of tools with you you
might know
better paragraph structure you might
do better bridges in and out of your
chapters
you might know not to bring in too many
characters in the whole kitchen sink you
might have your themes broken down
your why broken down and your bigger
message and you know who you're writing
for
and you know what you're an expert in
but you're still new
it's still a fresh slate you're still
gonna have all the same butterflies in
your stomach
you're still gonna have all the same you
know
disembarking on this like amazing
journey and i always say books are a
journey not a destination
you're really not ever really getting
anywhere even like
you're you're in a journey like if you
get there the journey's over
books should continue forever explain to
me what a bridge is
between chapel a bridge is leading out
of one chapter
into the next chapter so it it either
summarizes and concludes
the the first the chapter that's just
ending
and leads you into the next chapter with
a flow
so you don't feel just that one chapter
ends and then the next chapter starts
there's some kind of with fiction it's a
little bit different especially if
you're jumping around locations but
there is some kind of
there's a there's a skill involved in
leading the reader
in through like a tapestry of the
chapters and that's what the bridges do
and that's really what we do in the
third draft as we work on the bridges
how can you tell a story is boring or
it's wandering
what tips do you have to like you said
with the one gentleman who had an
interesting career
but it needed it needed
these 15 tips i like people to write
their story first
first draft before i start killing their
babies is what i the way i call it and
that's um
i get pretty brutal like i'll start to
go through and just be like
why do we care and who's this for and
what does this do
and why do we need this and if i get
some pushback
i'll listen because there could be
something that isn't really be
being said and we'll have sometimes like
a debate about it
like well what do you mean that the the
the that you say that this is about that
character's
evolution i don't see any evolution here
at all i see you're just washing dishes
in the kitchen with their grandmother
where's the evolution well the
grandmother threw the thing
and well you didn't write that the
grandmother threw the thing you just
wrote
oh then they go and write it
and it's now a scene that
almost is like required
so you don't try to you don't try to
throw up you might have entire
storylines that just go
right because sometimes it seems
all seems relevant on the first draft
and then in the second draft
we don't need everybody to know every
single
part of your life we just need the parts
that serve the themes that are running
through
and if that chunk does not serve the
theme
they're not going to know the difference
whether you kept it out or not because
they don't know you
they only know what you're going to tell
them you want them to know
so if we're like oh grandpa john he
would make these great birdhouses and
he's just
no do we is grandpa john necessary right
to the story
oh he was a really cool guy he was i
would we would watch these no
no is he necessary right no grandpa
john's gone
sorry yeah and how do people feel about
that when it's like
that was grandpa john he's got to be in
the store he was a big part of the
family
but there wasn't enough and i'm like you
can put grandpa john in the book for
grandpa john but that's not going to
help your book
we need to focus on the book what does
the book need what is you know maybe you
can
write a little letter to grandpa john or
something put them in the put them in
the acknowledgments
okay right with a picture no well that's
right we're not doing pictures
no pictures no graphics
you